welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of The Lord
of the Rings the rings of Power episode
3 and episode 4. I'm doing my best to
keep up with this series but you know
with the d23 news House of the Dragon
She-Hulk and or in Daily blood
sacrifices to Jake the talking goat
fitting in Jeff bezos's Flex has been
tough but I love this series so much and
there's so many details to appreciate so
I'm gonna go through some really cool
stuff that was pretty easy to miss from
episode three and then dive deep in
episode four first some more things to
say about this beautiful opening title
sequence creative director Anthony
vitagliano confirmed that the look was
inspired by Childish figures wherein
sand is vibrated by sound to show
different wavelengths a phenomenon
called cymatics planes of Yonder the
production company that made these
explained that this is all meant to show
tolkien's ainor the Angelic Spirits
whose songs literally constructed this
world of Arda so when we see these Sans
forming the two trees of Eleanor we are
literally seeing the creation myth of
this world with Howard Shore's score as
the songs of the einer until his darker
horn section snakes in to represent
represent the invasive evil of morgoth
and Sauron now for episode 3 let's take
its Storyline by storyline starting with
Aaron dear erendir is dragged into this
nightmare that the Orcs have been
digging under the Southlands of all time
the whole time turning this into what we
now know will be the future Mordor
actually back in episode 1 the austereth
Watchtower overlooking the zaplands
lines up perfectly with a long distant
Peak a volcano a likely candidate for
Mount Doom notice how the opening shot
shows him taking in the sunlight
blocking tarps of her head little beams
of light annoying the Orcs and hearing
them bickering about who gets sunlight
Duty you can see him gradually forming
this plan to just slice that tarp open
to expose them all to sunlight later on
in the episode now as we revisit the
storyline later in the episode the map
crossfades from a tree into the
live-action tree which these elf diggers
put up a stand to protect because trees
are hugely significant to elves and a
Tolkien look no further than the ends of
course these elves are scarred with what
happened to their ancestors with the
Trees of valinor when his friend gets
killed Aaron deer sadly tells it
which in Queen Yang translates to
forgive me now later Muriel talks about
the white tree being descended from the
Valar pieces of the Trees of Eleanor and
actually the seeds of this tree will
later be carried to Middle Earth by a
sildor to plant the white tree in Gondor
that we see a man Osteria and Peter
Jackson's return to the king that tree
starts off dead and then starts to
Blossom again when Aragorn returns but
in tolkien's writing Aragorn physically
replants his sapling Toki [ __ ] loves
Streets back in the ditch revion
speculates about adahar Saron was said
to have many names in days of old
perhaps this is one of them there's more
at work here than we can get to see yeah
notice how the first part of that line
looked like it was ADR that was added in
post-production because we don't see the
active space on screen when he says that
the audio sounds slightly different
suggesting that this is a very important
line that producers of this episode
needed to be in there to set up
something else the closing shot teases
at our who's played by Joseph mull
benjen Stark from Game of Thrones he
himself is not Sauron most likely his
name translates to father because it's
the name that the Orcs that he birthed
gave him and he is more likely a minion
of Sauron or someone working alongside
Sauron towards the same objective now in
the Galadriel numenor storyline Clash
Royale awakens in the ship immediately
notice reaches for finrod's dagger at
her side and it's not there halbrand
always super observant notices that how
desperate she is to get it back how
fearful she is to not have it and how he
can prove himself indispensable to her
by quelling that fear notice how later
we see him eyeing that dagger at
Ellendale's side and when he hugs Ellen
deal in the throne room he totally
swipes it off him and right after you
can see that dagger gone from Ellen
Deal's side and you can make out how
brand holding it flush against his arm
as they walk up the steps he does a
similar kind of sleight of hand with the
guild pin later on but anyway we made
Ellen deal this episode a captain of
numenor numenor is a star-shaped Island
Kingdom between Middle Earth and valinor
numenor was given to the humans by the
Velar the gods of this world for siding
with elves against morgoth in the
previous age and as a result of
numenorian humans live extended lives
but not as long as the lives of elves
towering over this Harbor is a statue of
AR and deal father to elrond and his
twin brother elrose elrose whom we see
on the tapestry later on notice how the
statue's hand is outstretched welcoming
a contrast to the Future statues of the
arganoff and Middle Earth those actually
will depict an older version of isildur
and his brother anarian El India's Sons
now we have not met an Ariane yet but
the show does add a new character their
sister ayarian the AR and deal statue
has a similar Jewel on his crown and a
bird beside him that represents elrond
and elrose's mother El Wing who did take
bird form at one point and noticed the
way the statue gazes out is exactly how
Caleb rimmore describes him later in
episode 4. he had that way of seeing
far off elrond actually speaks about Air
India later my father single-handedly
sailed to valinor and convinced the
valard to join the war in Vanquish
morgoth so great were his deeds that the
Valar lifted him beyond the bounds of
this world to Forever carry the evening
star across the sky a legend that even
the harfoots like sudok know about her
pair the beans were turned into Stars
never the other way around
Aaron deal is what galadrio will later
gift to Frodo in The Fellowship of the
Ring I give you the light of erenil our
most beloved star may it be a light for
you in Dark Places when all other lights
go out now as they walk through the
kingdom halliburon's eyes light up when
he passes the forge where the fire rages
and he later begs the blacksmith to let
him work there telling you there is not
another man on this aisle that knows
this craft better than us Albert even
gets into a huge fight just to try to
get a guild pin so he can work in this
Forge I think the clues are very clearly
pointy to how Brad's secretly being our
Sauron ladies and gentlemen his interest
in forging his skill at winning people
over but is secretly violent nature
checks all the boxes of what we should
expect from a master of Deceit who's
going to fool all these characters at
some point we're basically looking for
an antichrist and I think we got one
here notice how even when the guys ask
his name he cryptically says to Ben
depends on what how close we are which
absolutely recalls revion's line earlier
about sauron's mini names but they
agreed to the queen regent Muriel
no one kneels
sorry well the future heir of Ellen deal
and a seal door and the whole numenorian
lineage of men through Gondor Aragorn
will
look similar
you bow to no one you'll notice
farazone's tunic is covered with the
guild pins that the Smiths only have one
of showing that he has mastered a number
of crafts and areas of civic
responsibility now on the deck of the
ship isildura hears a female voice
[Music]
this happens again of course in episode
four getting the steel door kicked off
of the crew Soldier is looking off
beyond the Western shores of numenora
toward valinor because he thinks this is
that the one ring will speak to him in
when it corrupts him in Mount Doom now
Peter Jackson's films framed to seal
jurors corruption through gladriel and
elrond's recounting of it but in truth
it wasn't just pure evil that caused him
to say
take the ring he initially just took
that ring as a token of the family that
he had lost in this battle so I think
we're seeing how this series is going to
redeem the character of his sealed her
it's not that he was evil it's just that
he was weakened by things that all men
are weakened by and I like how in these
episodes we get an interesting contrast
isilter helps pull Emery Hill back on
the boat whereas back in episode 2
halbrand immediately pried his part of
the rapt away from the others to save
himself and doom all of them to death
Muriel gives Ellen deal this sword which
at first I thought could be the narsal
sword you know the one that shatters and
is used by his son isilder to cut the
ring off sauron's hand but actually
narcel totally does show up later in
episode 4 the room with a palantir along
with the ax and a swan decorated Shield
a tour I love a good room build with
Easter eggs Allendale speaks quenya to
Glad rail where I was raised many speak
it
it is still taught in our Hall of law
still carved on statues throughout the
city if you look closely enough and he
points to an elf statue covered by
divines indeed throughout numenor the
Elvish iconography is he had buried over
time in episode 4 aaryn and a sealder
meet in front of a mural depicting elves
and Men working together to fight off a
sea creature but that paint has been
left to peel away Galadriel connects
sauron's digital with a map of the
Southlands and she reads this black
speech plan to create Mordor this text
is written in a ring around the symbol
like a certain Elvish warning inscribed
in the One Ring in Lord of the Rings now
Ellendale tells his son a sealder the
watery part of this world has a way of
healing even deep
words interesting word choice for these
seafarers who chant the phrase the sea
is always right why not say to your son
the sea will heal your wounds instead of
the watery part of this world well I
think it's a nod to isildur's fate he
will drown in a river at the end of his
life a river being a general watery part
of the world and when the One Ring parts
from him in that moment in a way it does
heal his wounds of the burden that was
on him then on to the hard votes of this
episode or Largo is injured but it's not
really healed and he tells his wife
Marigold you know after our last Rose
it was like
that we use broke out from under me I
just like how in all these scenes the
hard puts revolve all of their
references to things like wheels and the
path because that is their entire
cultural identity now the Harper's
memorialized those they had lost in the
past Year's migration having a chance of
their own we wait for you and this
includes Poppy's entire family that was
lost in a landslide my God but then they
all freaking laugh at a hard foot who
died from bees bees bees not the Bears
have you not seen my girl this guy is
dead you but then our poor giant meter
man goes fire bad and burns the star map
and bulldozes through their camps so
saddock moves the Brady puts to the back
of the Caravan which is essentially a
death sentence we know if you think
about it someone always has to be at the
back of the line so whoever that current
Caboose must be like oh Randy wiggle
toes is moving up kiss me [ __ ] in
the wrong tint wasn't the worst thing
that happened to us hey Our Food Spot
The Stranger helps them keep moving
I can't help but see this is another
Gandalf clue because remember that
moment in Fellowship what's the elvish
word for friend
better not oh and by the way those doors
of Duren totally designed for the
dwarves by our main caliber and Roar
thus his Fascination last episode with
that Dwarven technology episode 4 opens
open zastrous vision of pneumonor being
swallowed by the Sea the Petals of the
white tree cry those tears of the Valar
their judgment and wrath sinking in this
Kingdom the pointed balcony crumbles and
if this architecture reminds you of
Minas tirith that is by design that City
will get established by this branch of
humans in a later age this episode is
titled The Great Wave and this is the
same wave of numenor referenced by
faramir and tolkien's Return of the King
token himself wrote in letters to
readers that he was haunted by a
recurring nightmare of a wave towering
over the green inlands so here Muriel is
seeing tolkien's nightmare come to life
but then when we cut to Muriel Awakening
she's not waking up from a dream she's
already kind of sitting up her eyes open
that's because this is not a dream it
was a vision from the palantir scene
Stone Adar introduces himself to Aaron
dear as a fellow Sylvan L from Valerian
the sunken landmass from the war of
Wrath which may inform why Adar is so
motivated to help build a new kingdom in
the Southlands we learned that Bronwyn
and the others have fled to that
Watchtower reminding us of the refugees
that Helms Deep but they're running out
of food so Theo and South Nebraska and
go back for food Theo tries to stay in
the late when he packs up that food in
that house but the door behind him
closes trapping him in the darkness he's
able to repel the orc with his Broken
Sword using his own blood to let it grow
notice how he slices off that orc's
fingers with the incomplete blade
another possible nod to narsil which of
course will do this to sauron's hand in
Linden dwarves and elves collaborate to
construct Keller brimbora's Forge Tower
I love how you can see down there the
elves standing beside the shorter
dwarves every wide shot of this show is
just so intricately designed and
beautiful including the look of these
cranes notice how they have a specific
spiral designed to them this actually
lines up perfectly with the proportions
of the golden ratio just giving you a
sense of how Genius of Engineers these
dwarves are another thing I love about
this series is how expertly it employs
light and darkness in the storytelling
like in this scene when elrond visits
kazad Doom to investigate Duran Duran
leans enclosed to his wife diza we're
making great progress in the old mine in
that moment the mirrored light beams of
Moria revealed the truth of their
deception and if you remember diesel
told her kids to change
to chant Rich Crone kisses
kisses and gold because that is the
secret password for the old mind now
this massdorf guard as elrond if he's
lost this is actually actor Dave Chapman
who performs and voices b2emo in Star
Wars and or just want to shout this guy
out because I love what he's doing in
that series Duren reveals to elrond that
they have been mining Me Thrill The Ore
that of course will be used in the chain
mail that Bilbo later gives Frodo but
during lets elrond keep this big chunk
of mithril which might be the same
mithril that Keller brimbor will later
use to forge nenya the mithril ring that
Galadriel wears and of course whenever
you try to ask her about it she's always
like ninja business this one's mine
collateral and halibrand end up sharing
neighboring cells and numenor's dungeon
a room with a huge statue of the sea
goddess meaning that this was not always
a dungeon it's a repurposed room with a
previous function the fact that numenor
needs dungeons at all it's not a great
sign definitely a sign that they aren't
doing what the Bell are intended but how
Brad has this fascinating bit of wisdom
you do well to identify what it is that
your opponent most fears
and exploited no
give them a means of mustering it so
that you
can muster them
I mean come on Sauron at least try to
hide it a bit better because of course
Sauron will successfully trick men and
elves and dwarves into forging 19 Rings
mastering their fears all so that he
could Master them with his one ring of
power Muriel unveils to gladriel the
palantir one of the seven scene stones
made by the noldor in valinor believed
to be made by fanor himself of course
another one of these is used by sour man
and Lord of the Rings I just love the
visual detail of the palantir cracking
it's shattering outward and then framing
glad rail inside of those cracks as if
to show how these Visions are
essentially cracking and shattering
one's hopes for the future with a
prophecy of Doom our endear saves Theo
who honestly I would have left in the
well but they're saved by sunlight and
as the sun rises over the mountains we
realize the female singing voice have
been hearing is that of disa resonating
to communicate with the mountain like
she talked about in episode two and I
love it the way these grains vibrate on
the stone matches perfectly with the
opening credits imagery there was the
INR creating Arda here it is a similar
process of angelic music moving the
grains of the earth now waldrig reveals
to Theo that he knew that he stole the
hilt and shows the mascara where he had
been using his blood to keep it alive
all this time the fact these people have
needed their blood to feed it suggest
that without a human host it would have
died out all it takes is one spark of a
Believer to keep the evil alive but
waldrake tells Theo that he interpreted
the meteor as a sign of sauron's coming
return but you know what does waldrick
know really but in a way that could
still be true about the meteor that the
Valar still sent this stranger but
rather than a sign of Doom a sign of
concern a bit of help to face that Doom
because yes I am still assuming that
this is an estari Gandalf sent as a
defense against the Rings and against
Sauron meanwhile I'm still speculating
that Theo is gonna end up becoming one
of The Naz schools if anything is
happening too fast like slow down kids
save some of that blood to surrender to
Sauron in season three and as Muriel
sends Galadriel away those white tree
petals just SOB everywhere which she
reads is a signal that parting ways with
Galadriel is a huge mistake so she
decides to give Galadriel an army but is
this the right move I mean it's
impossible to know like Galadriel and
Muriel we the viewers know the eventual
fate of all these characters how they're
gonna be fooled by Sauron and fail each
other yet this show asks us to be led by
faith and not by fear because in this
series there will be moments of Triumph
as well it's only a passing thing the
shadow even Darkness must pass but a new
day will come and when the sun shines
it'll shine out the clear those are the
stories that stay with you that meant
something folks and those stories had
lost their chances of turning back only
they didn't they kept going because they
were holding on to something that
there's some good in this world Mr Frodo
and it's worth fighting for yeah I'll
take every excuse to force those
Immortal words in every conversation
because this world is too dark and we
all need to hear it as much as possible
and I'm gonna do my best to keep
fighting for the good of keeping up with
this series thank you for your patience
you can follow me on Tick Tock Instagram
and Twitter at eavos follow new Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
thank you